[موسيقى] [موسيقى]
أجنبية
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، أنا أجنبي أبدأ
بتهنئتك على
أنه فيلم رائع حقًا إنه مؤثر حقًا
وأيضًا
كان الأداء مجنونًا تمامًا
كيف حققت ذلك جيدًا أه شكرًا جزيلاً لك
أعني أنه كان فيلمًا صعبًا  افعل
ذلك لأنه كما قلت بحق ،
يمتد نوعًا ما إلى 50 عامًا ، لذا لديك
الشخصيات في السبعينيات والثمانينيات والتسعينيات ثم
في عام 2000 ،
وبالتالي كل قسم سواء كان
تصميمًا إنتاجيًا ، سواء كان
مظهر الفيلم ، يجب أن يتغير كل شيء
وفقًا لذلك.  حتى ذلك الوقت ،
كان فيلمًا ثقيلًا للغاية
وفيلمًا مليئًا بالتحديات حقًا
ولكنه ممتع جدًا للقيام به أيضًا
[موسيقى]
ما يجعل هذه الشخصية مميزة جدًا ،
فهو يرى دائمًا الجانب الجيد من الأشخاص ،
نعم هذا صحيح جدًا فهو شخص
نقي جدًا  قلب وبريء جدًا وليس
لديه أي سلبية فيه ، لذا
فهو شخص شامل ودافئ للغاية
وأنت على حق ، فهو لا يرى سلبية
في أي شخص ، إما
أنها شخصية ملهمة للغاية
لأنني  يعالج الكثير من القضايا
بما في ذلك
التنمر ، أحد المشاهد المفضلة لدي في
هذا الفيلم هو عندما يركض آه لال
والدعامة قادمة ، هل يمكنك أن تخبرنا
عن هذا المشهد ،
نعم إنه مشهد رائع وهو
كما تعلم في هذا
فيلم شخصية لال نقي القلب
وبريء لدرجة
أن الكثير من المعجزات تحدث في الحياة
وإحدى المعجزات هي أن
دعاماته فجأة يمكنه أن يبدأ في
الجري ويكاد يركض كما لو كان يطير
وهذا هو جمال  هذا الفيلم الذي
تعرفه هو أيضًا أحد اللحظات المفضلة لدي
عندما تنفجر الأقواس فجأة
وتنكسر ،
يبدو الأمر كما لو أن الكون
يتآمر لفعل أشياء له
إيجابية
للغاية ومعجزة للغاية
لأن
أم
[الموسيقى]
ظهرت في الفيلم ماذا يفعل  هذا يعني
بالنسبة لك ،
لقد كان من المدهش حقًا أن يقوم
بهذا الدور وأنت تعلم أننا كنا
نبحث في الأصل الذي كان لديك إلفيس
بريسلي ، لذلك أردنا أن يكون إلفيس
بريسلي الهندي شخصًا نجمًا ضخمًا نعم
و و  كان Sharokina هو الخيار الواضح
بالنسبة لنا ، فهو شخص واحد
من أكبر النجوم الذين شاهدتهم الهند على الإطلاق
،
وهو رجل مذهل
وعندما طلبناه إذا كان بإمكانه أن يلعب دوره
في فيلمنا وكان
كريمًا ودافئًا للغاية.  وقال
نعم بالطبع سأفعل ذلك ، ومن
الرائع حقًا أن يفعل هذا الأمير كما تعلم في
الشرق الأوسط ، فنحن نحب أفلام هوليوود
ولكن عندما يتعلق الأمر ببوليوود ، فإننا نحبها
أكثر هل تساءلت عن سبب
تخميني لذلك  ربما عاطفيًا ،
نحن على مفتاح يشبه إلى حد كبير
الأمريكيين
الأمريكيين ، لذا أعتقد أن الهنود لديهم
مفتاح عاطفي أقرب
إلى العالم العربي
والشرق الأوسط
أه وفي الواقع حتى الشرق الأقصى وأنت تتجه
نحو الصين على ما أعتقد
الثقافات في هذا الجزء من
العالم في الشرق لديها تشابه معين
في مفاتيحها العاطفية
[تصفيق]
أي شيء تريد إخباره لجميع
معجبيك في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط أريد أن
أشكرهم على كل الحب الذي قدموه
دائمًا  أنا  وعملي
أه أنا سعيد جدًا بذلك
نعم كنت أقول إننا صنعنا هذا الفيلم
بالكثير من الحب والرعاية
وآمل أن
نتمكن من لمس قلوب الناس
بالطريقة التي لمستنا بها بينما كنا
نصنع  فيلم وآمل أن يكونوا قد استمتعوا
به ، إنه فيلم رائع للغاية ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك على الوقت الذي
قضيته في الإجابة على أسئلتي وأنا متحمس حقًا
للجميع في الشرق الأوسط
لمشاهدته قريبًا ، شكرًا لك أمير ،
شكرًا لك